LAURENCE MORONEY: Welcome
to Coffee with a Googler.
Today I'm going to be chatting
with Shanea King-Roberson,
and we're going to be taking a
look at this new course called
Firebase in a Weekend.
It comes from Google and
Udacity working together.
And if you're not
familiar with Udacity,
they're the experts
in online training.
We're going to have a whole
lot of fun chatting about it,
and I hope you have a whole
lot of fun watching it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: So, Shanea,
welcome to Coffee with Googler.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON:
Thanks for having me.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
And I know you've
been really busy with
getting lots of courses out
and Udacity stuff, but you
have a very special course
to tell us about today.
Could you--
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: enlighten us.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: I'm
really excited about it, yeah.
We've been really busy.
We're actually launching
a new Firebase course.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON:
You know Firebase, right?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Kind of.
I've heard of it.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON:
Oh, my gosh.
Firebase is our new mobile
backend as a service.
It allows anyone to
use, create quickly,
a mobile backend for an Android
or iOS app and web, as well.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And web.
Can't forget the web.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Yeah.
This course is going to focus
immediately on Android and iOS.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: And so
we're really, really excited
about it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Now, so, this course,
it's called Firebase
in a Weekend?
Right?
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Oh, yeah.
This is actually a little
bit different than any
of the other Udacity
courses that we've created.
There's a lot that comes
into mobile development.
There's a ton of
different aspects.
This course is called
Firebase in a Weekend
because we want new,
intermediate, advanced
developers, anyone
to be able to get up
and running on Firebase as a
mobile backend in one weekend.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
In one weekend.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Yeah.
You want to take a look?
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sure.
INSTRUCTOR: Let's dive into
the Firebase real time database
structure.
All data is stored
as JSON objects.
You can think of the
database as a cloud host
of [? JSONtry. ?] This means
that your entire database is
stored as a single JSON object.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: I was
just joking earlier.
Of course I'm familiar
with Firebase.
You know, it's a
suite of technologies.
And some of it's really to
help you develop better apps.
And some of it's
to grow your apps
and then to earn from them.
And I know in this
weekend you're
focusing on the
development of the app
so you get that foundation.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And there's
a bunch of technologies.
Which ones does the
course actually cover?
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: So
it covers authentication.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON:
Which is a really exciting.
It covers the
real-time database.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Security.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON:
And, what we're
really excited about
is, like you just
said, getting all of
the foundations set up,
because Firebase, like you
said, is a suite of options.
But what's really
exciting is we actually
teach you to get all
those foundations set up,
ready to go, so you can really
just focus on the really fun
things in the app.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: The
UI design, the engagement,
the earning, all of
those different things.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sweet.
So it's a sweet suite.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So,
typically with Udacity
you do this by building an app.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
I assume there's
like an app that's going
to be built in this.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Oh yeah.
Absolutely.
So we're really excited because
we are actually teaching people
to build one of our
favorite demo apps, which
is called Friendly Chat.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Friendly Chat?
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON:
Friendly Chat.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON:
It is a messaging app.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON:
So by the end of it,
we are able to see messages
coming back and forth.
You're able to
authenticate users,
multiple people are able
to chat with each other.
And also we teach
you a new library,
which is called
Firebase Auth UI which
makes authentication UI
really easy and really simple
on both Android and iOS.
So you have all the
foundation to get up
and running and chatting
with your friends,
learning how to use all of
the remote config messaging,
all of those different things.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON:
Right off the bat.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
You mentioned remote config,
and that's one of my favorites.
Right?
That with remote config
it's very, very simple
for you to just change
your UI on the fly,
because it's a
server-side variable.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So instead of you
needing to deploy
a new code base,
if you need to make changes,
or you need to make tweaks,
you can do it by reading these
variables out of the cloud.
It's mind-blowing.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON:
It's going to be-- It's
so much better for developers.
It's much faster and simpler.
And so what we really
try to do with Firebase
is teach for an end
to end, hand-holding,
there's a video
instructor, so that people
feel as though they're
interacting with a real person
teaching them how
to build this app,
rather than just reading
the documentation.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And one
of the things that I really
like about how Udacity
do it, is that it's
a very Socratic method.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's not like
your typical video training
where you sit back and watch
a screen cast for two hours.
Hopefully you've got it all.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: [LAUGHING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: How
would you explain it?
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Yeah,
so Udacity is actually
really good for engagement.
You watch short chunks of video.
So two to three minutes,
maybe five tops.
But then it's immediately
followed by an assessment.
What we want to do is make
sure that in every node
you get a chunk of information,
you really learn that piece.
You can embody that piece
before you move forward.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON:
And then you're
able to move back
and forth, rather
than trying to scroll
through a two-hour video
to find that one sentence
that you're looking for.
Everything is broken
up into notes,
which makes it really helpful.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
I personally, for me,
because I don't have
great retention,
that when it's short
like that and it's
challenged with a little bit of
a quiz, it forces me to think.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Right.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And I might
only spend like a half an hour
learning in a particular
day, if I'm doing something
like this, rather than
three or four hours,
but I retain so much
more in that time.
Because it's much more intense,
it's much more concentrated.
And I still remember some
of these years later.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: And
you're super hands on with it
because you're
actually building.
You know, you're
using GitHub, you're
learning the different things,
you're looking at the difs,
you're seeing all of
these different changes.
And they're small changes, so
you really understand and see
the progression from start
to finish rather than just
trying a bunch of things out and
saying, "Does this really fit
together with this?"
It takes you in a linear order.
So you kind of get a round
view of what's happening.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So the
obvious next question
is, where do we get started?
How do I get this course?
How do I learn it?
And how much is
going to cost me?
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON:
Absolutely.
So developers can access the
course at no cost to them.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
INSTRUCTOR: They can just go
to Udacity.com/Google and click
on Firebase in a Weekend.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So the
entire course, no cost?
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON:
No cost to them.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
So I can learn all of
these things in a weekend?
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON:
Absolutely.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Wow.
I've got to go try it out.
And there's one other
thing that they will learn
and that's how not
to cook a burger.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Yes.
A veggie burger.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Yes, of course.
And you'll have to watch
the course to find out.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON:
Absolutely.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
thank you so much Shanea.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON: Of course.
Thanks for having me.
LAURENCE MORONEY: This
has been so much fun.
I'm really looking forward to
seeing the finished product.
I've seen little bits of
it and I taught some of it.
And I just can't wait to
see the finished product
and developers, I think,
are going to love it.
SHANEA KING-ROBERSON:
We're really proud of it.
Thank you so much, Laurence.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Thank you.
So, if you want to learn
more about this course,
go take a look at
Udacity.com/Google.
And as always, if you
have any questions for me
or if you've any
questions for Shanea,
just leave them in
the comments below.
And don't forget to hit
that Subscribe button.
Thank you.